[Musique]
inspiré par les films publicitaires
émerveillé par tout c'est miraculeux
produits qui ouvre les portes du bonheur
nous avons décidé de vous présenter une
belle histoire d'amour permettez-nous
d'ajouter que toute ressemblance entre
les produits figurant dans ce film et
des produits existants ou ayant
réellement existé ne peut être que
fortuite et certainement pas de leur
destine
[Musique]
m
je suis triste
et bien jours que se passe-t-il
est ce que tu vas tu tiens moi je
tombais amis c'est jocelyne je laime je
crois que même pas ce qui se passe ça
faut être là proche à un mouvement de
recul comme suit va dégoûter aller à
chelsea et flatte jeu d'entreprise des
amoureux le seul remède contre la
mauvaise année place le dentifrice qui
donne une haleine érotique c'est la
solution à son problème
aucune femme ne résiste à chouette
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
georges bouchard a essayé schlatt et les
résultats ne se sont pas fait attendre
aucune femme ne résista schlatt c'est le
début d'une belle histoire d'amener les
tourtereaux échange des serments mais ma
chemise je la croyais blanche au même
taille est pas mon chéri la lessive
clash serait pas ce petit en un clic la
planche classe n'est comparable à une
autre
[Musique]
or donc et délicieux quel goût de la rom
c'est formidable que je n'ai pas de
mérite mon chéri gens prennent le café
ce compte il fait de grains sélectionner
un ingrat médiocre et toujours éliminé
parce qu'en mai ça c'est merveilleux je
me sens dans une forme mais dans une
forme ce qu on est nerveux pas il donne
de l'énergie
et oui mais c'est pas non seulement il
faut bien il parce que j'ai beaucoup de
travail ce matin
s'est-on qu'un chef des hommes ils
n'étaient pas pas maintenant je dois un
seuil et mes cheveux avec fritsch eux
vous pensé au contrat
le voici déjà pensé que ce serait pas
par avance bien j'ai travaillé vite
monsieur de ballons je suis en forme en
ce moment et j'ai remarqué où ça n'est
dans mon bureau bien monsieur duval ont
bougé je vous observe depuis quelques
temps vous savez que depuis le départ à
la retraite monsieur lamarre ne passez
les sous directeurs est libre oui
monsieur directeur et bien je vous offre
ce poste de directeur
moi oui je sais il n'y a pas très
longtemps vous êtes dans la maison mais
quand énergie votre vitalité la
blancheur de broc chemise votre after
shave votre haleine enfin bref ce pas
cette info holmes monsieur le directeur
j'essaierai j'essaierai j'essaierai de
me rendre digne de votre confiance et
mon vieux prenez le réussir
et si nous ayons déjeuner chez vos jours
nous pourrions parler tranquillement
tout ça aujourd'hui
oui je vous avoue que j'aime bien voir
comment vivent mes proches
collaborateurs ailleurs et ma femme doit
venir dans quelques instants elle doit
se joindre à nous à moins que ça ne vous
dérange bien sûr non non non non non en
euros au congo contraire c'est un
plaisir
allo chérif c'est terrible c'est
terrible le père du banon s'est invité
chez nous avec sa bonne femme
1 oui aujourd'hui dans une demi heure
ils aiment bien manger
il y va de la situation enfin c'est
terrible mais non même temps qu'ils y
est pas oui oui tout sera prêt dans une
demi-heure
si nous nous associons ton mac est
splendide
vous venez de là serait est faite aux
non non non pas du tout mais je
rappelais cote pour la nettoyer avec
picotte un coup d'aspirateur et la
saleté 120-106 et la moquette
comme tout est brillant chez vous vous
êtes une ménagère incomparable non pas
du tout non mais j'emploie mende avec
mons pour les meubles et les cuivres
faire le ménage est un plaisir
kiki qui dit campagne et ce en quoi elle
est si brillant et les sig est oui et
nous ne nourrissons qu'avec web chabot
de watts qui contiennent toutes les
vitamines qui lui sont nécessaires à lui
d'un labo toile lustré et en plus c'est
bon et bien je vous laisse je vais finir
de préparer vos repas
c'est bien mais bien le jouer je vais
servir l'apéritif à moi excusez nous
elle est adorable et puis elle est si
gaie elle a des cheveux si brillant une
conversation tellement intéressant mais
jamais vraiment charmant et voilà
j'espère que vous aimez le foot à jade
dort et le seul apéritif à base d'herbes
aromatiques qui donne vraiment faim
[Musique]
votre avenir mon cher boujard
même si un petit foot je sens que nous
allons nous régaler ah oui oui enfin
vous savez c'est très simple à ma femme
n'a pas eu tant qu au delà vous êtes une
cuisine et un compas c'est est excellent
et je me sens si léger à là c'est parce
que j'ai fait toute ma cuisine à l'huile
pic
j'ai l'impression que je pourrais courir
un 100 bêtes ont il va falloir bien
vendu s'excuserait je vous accompagne et
vous ça vous avez une petite femme est
patent koroma régime islamiste
et quand on est à faire
sous-directeur très longtemps à veiller
on va bientôt nous quitter rester
directeur incendie chez chery je vais
être nommé directeur et c'est grâce à
toi la cdu du ballon enfin comment tu
fais ce repas en si peu de temps
regard des invités inattendus
un festin ponthus plat et c'est ainsi
que grâce à cela de plaute split chf
loach clac scotch temps l'exemple at
commencent les résistible ascension de
bouchard sous directeur
rapport le mode éthique directeur
[Musique]
directeur général et enfin président
directeur général
faisons pas ces messieurs je n'irai pas
par quatre chemins monsieur bouchard
avez vous songé à faire de la politique
politique - mais oui vous monsieur
bouchard on ne parle que de vous votre
dynamisme votre vitalité votre
magnétisme personnel la blancheur de
votre linge bref tout cela fait de vous
le candidat idéal ou des messieurs je
suis très flatté mais tout cela demande
réflexion n'est ce pas mes affaires
il faut hélas vous décidez tout de suite
vous n'ignorez pas que notre candidat
s'est tué en voiture n'était pas équipée
de pneus blues les pneus glutz ne dérape
pas sur la chaussée mouillée
monsieur vous avez su trouver les
arguments chez emporte ma décision je
suis votre homme
[Musique]
au terme d'une campagne exemplaire
georges bouchard est élu député au
premier tour félicitations mon vieux mon
vieux charles charles
j'ai tenu à ce que tu sois présent pour
fêter mon élection
non seulement parce que tu es mon
meilleur ami charles mais aussi et
surtout parce que tout a commencé grâce
à toi on surtout grâce à schlatt députés
ministres et bientôt ce sont les
élections présidentielles
et voici notre première fourchette 61 2%
à 62 4 % de voix pour georges bouchard
georges bouchard est donc élu président
de la république monsieur le président
monsieur le président monsieur le
président au charbon mais je sais pas
pourquoi ça s'est mis à se laver les
dents dentifrice othello qu'une femme
meure existe
[Applaudissements]
chars
[Musique]
ici ont déjeuné ensemble ça nous
permettrait de discuter sérieusement
sans être dérangé 10 on attendait lundi
mardi mercredi non plus j'ai des
déjeuners
que diriez vous de jeudi un savin
déjeuner vendredi alors parfait alors je
vous confirme ray pour le restaurant
c'est ça un vendredi
voilà un déjeuner d'affaires
ça commence comme ça et aujourd'hui nous
allons vous faire assister à un déjeuner
d'affaires typiques comme ça vous serez
madame ce qui s'y passe et vous
comprendrez mieux l'état dans lequel
vous revient votre mari après une dure
journée de labeur
donc monsieur bouchard a donné rendez
vous dans un très bon restaurant un
essieu malherbe wertheim ou chalon pour
traiter de notre très importante à faire
mais non mais non alors je suis dans le
quartier depuis 12h45 c'était 20 minutes
que je rame en parle pas ça ça devient
impossible de rouler en ville bientôt
pour appuyer votre silhouette
c'est tout alors me suis cassé à banos
en bois pas d'alcool journal non non non
vous avez raison mais non plus nombreux
après au plus tard veillée l'après midi
est fichu voile a produites dont tout de
même là on les attend dans ce
championnat me tue muscu le terme petit
ne concerne pas la quantité de 8 ce qui
versait dans les verres il est l'un
seulement pour réconforter moralement
nos deux hommes d'affaires vous
remarquerez qu'ils vont souvent soulager
leur conscience de cette façon là
pendant le déjeuner faut dire que
l'alcool de grains beaucoup moins nocif
que l'alcool de fouilles à bâle alcool
de grains de chamarande de mort taille
de l'école de fruits ça tape à propos
jour ça va mais excusez moi c'est un
gars que je tourne en parler ça devient
impossible de rouler en ville bientôt on
pourra plus rien me dit rien répond
quelque chose de beau alors un petit peu
hâlé barman aux petits noms mais il faut
dire que l'alcool de grains et beaucoup
moins nocif que
de fruits n'en parlait pas l'autre soir
j'ai vu ta poire ou la poire ce sens de
santé
vous savez les contrats bien sûr toute
atteinte à propos de sa boîte des
fréquences il ya eu des rumeurs
on dit même qu'il va être achetée
postulat jour excuses a fait une demi
heure que je tourne à eux c'est de la
folie quoi on parlait pas ça devient un
psy de roullens bientôt propulsion non
rien berman quatre petits muscles
[Musique]
jérémy est donc si on faisait notre menu
d'abord comme saab on pourra parler de
miracle il faut se débarrasser de toute
façon moi je mange léger à un mois aussi
a toujours aimé des tailleurs oui et si
on veut tenir bon alors qu'est ce que
vous avez à nous recommander de légers
pour commencer oui léger et bien il y
aller seul bréval ce sont des filets sur
le pocher avec une chose on a comme
frêche et du porto et des trucs
[Musique]
oui c'est sûr vie simplement avec des
petites pommes de terre et ses flamber
au cognac mais je n'ai pas lourd du tout
en produisant au long du tout alors va
pour les seules vraies balles tu as
quatre noms mais je prendrais du homard
mayonnaise chapon et moi je serai sur
les sols je vais manger les faits oui
moi aussi après je prendrai une grillade
mais simple oui plus simple un très
simple je me permets de signaler que le
gibier et bien a bien fait c'est vrai
qu'à part quand je lis billet bien ici
ça quand il est bien il est bien à oui
ça quand il est bien et nous avons reçu
les cailles dit qu'elles sont jamais
simplement avec un coût dix fois la et
la transmission aux coulisses hausse
mais sans mais pas trop de source ap
voilà le coulis mais pas trop de choses
mais vous le dis à mes gars bien mais
faut quand même un minimum fois r je
vous avais ras sans forcer sur les
sauces mais bien sûr pour les vins
messieurs pour les bacs oui ou non non
non pas de mélange à midi non oui mais
où
pour le poisson abondant alors il s'en
sort pas d'idée zaoui mais après alors
je dis bourgogne soit là celui ci est
très douloureux il est très bon le petit
sancerre et j'ai tellement bon et
l'egypte que nos hommes d'affaires en
ont commandé une deuxième bouteille la
conversation s'engage
l'insolent suprême maison a rappelé
richard des vacances passées en norme
mois pour les vacances j'ai vu chez nous
parce que ça vient tout gâcher
c'est comme ça quand à bali vous avez
fait ben ali
tahiti moi je vais très tenté par tjs
que cette mesure fait en attendant le
plat de résistance les hommes d'affaires
ont eu le temps d'évoquer plusieurs
problèmes importants
la voiture les spectacles et l'éducation
des enfants les problèmes de la jeunesse
il a été un peu distant de politique
mais pas trop car il sait révéler de
monsieur malherbe a des idées de gauche
ah c'est très très très polar ou là ou
là d'où sont là là là là ça va ça c'est
assez pour moi pour tous pour la sauce
tout ce temps de jeu parodique
doucement la source doucement doucement
la sauce
ça va merci oulala
m
on peut pas résister on y pêche à la
sauce s'amoncellent un petit bistrot où
ils ont une spécialité des caillons
feuilleter à merveille 20 c'est tout
près de la nationale 28
et justement d'arriver à carrer les
visages oui je connais pas je connais tu
sais pas mais diable pu très bien on y
mange très très bien à wylder quand vous
êtes là pour continuer un peu sur le
national vous prenez le 344 le concept
cars général à yann du restaurant ils
ont un de ces cas sous la casserole et
notaire ayant construit dans la cave de
vialas pas surfait ne pas du tout pas
d'accord au d'appartements tu vas
déjeuner d'affaires hier et croyez moi
c'est le succulent au moyen âge était la
calanque de mireille une bouillabaisse
vous l'avoir les oui mais non la
bouillabaisse doit manger dans le midi
voilà déjà pas les poissons ici ne
croyez pas vous connaissiez la
bouillabaisse torrance à strasbourg on
savait qu'on voulait on avait organisé
la acheminés à télé maintenant je pense
que j'ai encore un peu de sauce s'il
vous devez perdre on peut tomber manger
pendant la trêve
bush a demandé au téléphone les siens
bouchard je m je me demande si sa boîte
est vraiment un des deux façons il ya
des rumeurs par qui il paraît qu'il
était sûr à chaque mois on sait moins
que catastrophique alors paraîtrait même
que le
[Musique]
[Rires]
bonjour évidemment j'ai le dos tourné
quoique forcèrent secondes devant moi
c'est bien faire des fouilles précisons
pour la petite histoire que ce coup de
téléphone signal est un monsieur
bouchard qu'il avait quitté son bureau
en l'emportant la clé du coffre
empêchant le chef comptable de faire son
travail
[Musique]
il est parfait monsieur
c'est merveilleux acteurs et aux les
gros un petit peu plus ou moins souple
est la voie la part des très bien voilà
comme ça mais non et c'est ma famille
est aux petits dit pas non qu'est-ce que
vous avez un petit site a passé la poire
du patro à assat la part du patron ça se
refuse pas ah oui parce que la poire du
patron voyou un délai bien
bel et bien et bien au bout mais mes
enfants
bon si on parlait un peu de nos affaires
oui on est là pour ça aussi
oui à aa
il est 4 heures 10 oui c'est tout elle
n'attend pas il faut que je passe par
mon bureau j'ai le courrier ci vont
réguler un jour propose une nouvelle
édition chacun notre collègue way pour
chiens formés à un travail n'est pas
parfait et d'ici quelques jours on se
téléphone sur des jeunes
[Musique]
ce qui arrive à ce monsieur est très
banal un pneu de sa voiture a crevé il
se disposent donc à changer de roue mais
ce qui est intéressant c'est que ce
monsieur va se trouver en butte à la
méchanceté des choses il faut déjà noter
que le plu a choisi le crever le jour où
ce monsieur est à la fois bien habillés
et pressé il doit assister au mariage de
la fille de monsieur du vallon son
directeur monsieur duval on lui a fait
l'honneur de lui demander d'être le
témoin de mademoiselle du vallon mais
regardez ce qui va se passer
les tarots martic que si la route tient
par trois boulons il y en aura que deux
qui accepteront de quitter leur logement
sans faire de difficulté ce dernier
boulon les méchants il refuse de céder
il sait pourtant que tout dépend de lui
c'est sans doute pour ça d'ailleurs que
l'affreux sert de toutes ses forces
ce monsieur a tort de s'énerver il ne
peut rien contre la méchanceté des
choses
[Musique]
car les choses peuvent être méchante
sournoise cruel elles n'obéissent qu'à
une loi une vieille loi infernale est
bien connu
la loi de la tartine beurrée dont voici
les noms c'est tout tartine plonger vers
le sol donc du côté beurré nous allons
vous présenter quelques exemples
prouvant la méchanceté des choses
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
là encore c'est pas vrai coup de france
monticelli le tapis avec ton sens mais
c'est vrai j'ai déjà eu du mal à retirer
nos de la tartine
[Musique]
après ce petit intermède nous vous
présentons le coup de l'épinglé âmes
sensibles s'abstenir d'avoir coûté cher
[Musique]
et oui il reste toujours une épingle la
plus sournoise et maintenant un petit
exercice de physique déprimante le clou
vicieux le clou vicieux s'enfonce
toujours parfaitement au début
permettant les plus belles espérances
espérance wisches déçu car il refuse
obstinément de s'enfoncer plus loin que
la moitié de sa longueur
quelle que soit sa taille le clovis yeux
refusera toujours de s'enfoncer plus
loin que la moitié de sa longueur
[Musique]
il ya une foule qu'à claquer dans la
roseraie dépêche-toi déshabille devant
arriver d'un moment à l'autre
on y va on y va il existe chez nous deux
systèmes d'un pool les ampoules à
baïonnette qui dépèce et les ampoules
avis si vous avez grillé une antre où la
baïonnette
soyez sûr que l'ignoble et unique
ampoules de votre réserve sera avis et
réciproquement
faisons la triste expérience
alors ça vient comme si c'était fait
cqfd
[Musique]
rien n'égale l'horrible cruauté des
sauces leur sadisme s'exerce sur les
tissus délicats aux couleurs fragile et
quand une sauce vous êtes une cravate
unis élan frémit de juin
[Musique]
voyez ce pauvre monsieur qui essaie de
lutter contre la fatalité il est vaincu
davance tu manges pas chérie tu as tort
cette source est délicieuse
quoi qu'il fasse il est perdu
oh bah non écoute fait attention
mpk
[Musique]
excuser pour cause de la source
je pense vous a marqué juste leblanc a
tendance à attirer la sauce
on
m
des exemples de la méchanceté les choses
il y en a une infinité
[Musique]
niveau issu le lacet kick ass seulement
quand vous êtes pressé je suis la nuit
car c'est un salaire le bouton qui
sautent s'il est là c'est donc pas fait
leur travail
[Musique]
la pièce de monnaie cache-cache la
dernière allumettes de la boîte toujours
un combustible
[Musique]
avez vous remarqué que les fils sont
toujours un peu con cuir ou quelques cas
aujourd'hui
non mais pourquoi je vous invite ce soir
parce que je pensais la télévision ils
ont filmé toute la journée au bureau
[Musique]
sur fox aimerait que tout le monde
avance et moi moche et je vais tomber en
panne de porc
[Musique]
qu'il s'agisse de films souriant au
tragique le monde tel que nous le
présente habituellement le cinéma est
une sorte de paradis dont toutes les
petites contrariétés de la vie réelle
sont exclues pour vous prouver notre
propos nous allons prendre au hasard
quelques exemples qui vont vous montrer
le fossé séparant l'univers
cinématographique de notre vie
quotidienne
voici pour commencer comment se passe un
coup de téléphone au cinéma allô allô ma
chérie
chez moi
oh rien rien je voulais seulement tenir
à te sentir si loin de moi penser à cet
océan qui nous sépare ça m'a donné une
telle sensation solitude
c'était comme si mengue l'assument sur
elle que et maintenant voici le même
coup de téléphone dans la réalité
[Musique]
allô allô chéri c'est moi c'est moi
comment qui moi georges c'est georges un
nom à 20 mai mais attendez coupez pas
enfin je demande le 28 à l'eau
alors ma chérie c'est comme en stockant
- oui c'est encore moi enfin kate vous
afin qu'on use savez je peux tu peux
être aussi et moi aussi j'ai peut-être
une voix cocu mais vous savez ce qui
vous dit le cocu vous savez ce qu'ils
vous disent le cocu nous passons
maintenant à la traditionnelle scène du
dax gdaxi cinématographique s'entend
suivez cette voiture
[Musique]
inutile de vous dire que tout cela est
impensable dans la réalité
voyez plutôt taxi taxi ça va pas je suis
pas un cobaye moi alors je rentre à
levallois et puisque nous en sommes aux
taxis vous avez remarqué comme les
problèmes d'argent sont vite réglé au
cinéma
[Musique]
parce qu'en vérité
les choses sont souvent un peu plus
compliqué
n'avait pas de monnaie non j'en ai pas
je suis pas la banque de france moi
c'est fabu changer sa patate toi-même
watch travail
non mais ça va pas durer car été truquée
[Applaudissements]
si nous quittons les trajets urbains et
nous nous lançons dans les voyages au
long cours
nous nous apercevons que la différence
entre le cinéma et la réalité est encore
plus spectaculaire
dans un billet pour moi goodell s'est
passé je dois y est ou ce soir - good
invitation au dessus
[Musique]
radio pendant une heure vous avez
facilement entendre de france vous
trouverez certainement attaque six mois
là-bas on voyage monsieur monsieur
[Musique]
faudrait un billet pour moi bouddha je
suis passé faut que je sois ce soir ce
soir c'est que nous sommes très chargé
attendez je vous prie allô allô bonjour
ça va
dis moi est ce que tu as quelque chose
sur quoi bouddha à oui oui pour une
personne ah bah oui je sais c'est ce que
je disais à mon client tout à l'heure
ouais t'as rien d'autres à me proposer
ah bah quoi bon la seule possibilité ce
serait de vous mettre sur la liste
d'attentes dans quinze jours ah d'accord
d'accord a bien on peut dire vous avez
de la chance
une personne qui vient juste de se
désister en bon maintenant il y est vous
avez encore le temps de prendre l'avion
enfin si vous trouvez attaque 600 taxis
j'en fais mon a fait part fin je suppose
que vous avez votre visa bien entendu
qu'on vise non non il
il fallait un visa moi mon dieu mais oui
et ça prend dix jours pour la voir à
condition que vous ayez un passeport en
cours de validité
elle vous faudra aussi un extrait de
casier judiciaire enfin pour les vaccins
la variole à la fièvre jaune le choléra
ça suffit et puisque nous en sommes au
voyage voici ce qui se passe dans un
hôtel cinématographe
[Musique]
oh
rien tu renvoies mais certainement
monsieur nous allons vous donner la
chambre nuptiale aux chasseurs le sens
du
[Musique]
y'a pas taxi au même hôtel même scène
mais ce n'est plus du cinéma offrir une
chambre
nous voudrions une chambre vous avez
réservé à ben non alors il n'y a rien
nous sommes complets désolé complet
complet absolument complet un détail
encore avez vous remarqué l'exiguïté et
l'élégance du bagage cinématographique
[Musique]
et c'est pourtant dans ces petites
valises que notre couple trouvera une
inépuisable garde-robe
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
quelle différence avec nos bagages
habituel les couteaux a pris mon goût
jean à leur écoute plus un toit j'ai
pris qu'une robe de rechange
oui bah c'est pas une raison mais j'ai
pas de chaussettes non plus voilà tu
m'as appris qu'un gilet de corps
[Musique]
avouez que vous aimeriez connaître
l'adresse de ses admirables restaurant
qui relève plus de la cinématographie et
de la gastronomie
[Musique]
qu'est ce que te dire n'importe quoi
alors n'importe quoi à bord de ce que
vous voudrez bien monsieur noël
là encore la fiction dépasse la réalité
maître d'hôtel avec un maître d'hôtel
s'il vous plaît monsieur
enfin c'est pas trop tôt alors deux
plaies du jeu pour commencer la
diffusion sur rue de leur tomber tout
seuls leurs hits vous d'accord alors
doridot il n'y a plus de riz de veau
monsieur plus du tout à la fin d'un
homme ce que vous voudrez n'y en a plus
monsieur
[Musique]
au cinéma les bouteilles font toujours
ça jamais ça et les petits réveil sont
toujours comme ça
[Musique]
la charge dari
jamais comme ça à l'eau mais qu'est ce
que c'est quoi
mais que le rideau envion pour terminer
la vitalité de nos frères
cinématographique
[Musique]
non
établi que vous et qu'il arrive six
malfrats qui ont essayé de me tacler une
douche et oui ce qui ne paraît pas parce
que hélas dans la vie une simple baffe à
des effets bien plus spectaculaire
[Musique]